in this segment we'll introduce a model
with multiple parameters and multiple
observations it is a model that appears
in countless real-world applications but
instead of giving you a general and
abstract model we will talk about the
specific context that has all the
elements of the general model but it has
the advantage of being concrete and we
can also visualize the results the model
is as follows somebody is holding a ball
and throws it upwards this ball is going
to follow a certain trajectory what kind
of trajectory is it according to
Newton's laws we know that it's going to
be described by a quadratic function of
time so here is a plot of such a
quadratic function where this is the
time axis and this variable here X is
the vertical displacement of the ball
the ball initially is at a certain
location at a certain height theta 0 it
is thrown upwards and it starts moving
with some initial velocity theta 1 but
because of the gravitational force it
will start eventually going down so this
parameter theta 2 which will actually be
negative reflects the gravitational
constant suppose now that you do not
know these parameters you do not know
exactly where the ball was when it was
thrown you don't know what the exact
velocity and perhaps you also live in a
strange gravitational environment and
you do not know the gravitational
constant and you would like to estimate
those quantities based on measurements
if you are to follow the Bayesian
inference methodology what you need to
do is to model those variables as random
variables and think of the actual
realized values as realizations of these
random variables and we also need some
prior distributions for these random
variables we should specify the joint
PDF of these three random variables a
common assumption here is to assume that
the random variables involved are
independent of each other
and each one has a certain prior where
do these priors come from
if for example you know where is the
person that's throwing the ball if you
know their location within let's say a
meter or so you should have a
distribution for theta naught that
describes your state of knowledge and
which has a width or standard deviation
of maybe a couple of meters so the
priors are chosen to reflect whatever
you know about the possible values of
these parameters then what is going to
happen is that you're going to observe
the trajectory at certain points in time
for example at a certain time t1 you
make a measurement but your measurement
is not exact it is noisy and you record
a certain value at another time you make
another measurement and you record
another value at another time you make
another measurement and you record
another value and similarly you get
multiple measurements on the basis of
these measurements you would like to
estimate the parameters let us write
down a model for these measurements we
assume that the measurement is equal to
the true position of the ball at the
time of the measurement which is this
quantity plus some noise and we
introduce a model for these noise random
variables we assume that we have a
probability distribution for them and we
also assume that they're independent of
each other and independent from the
Thetas it is quite often that measuring
devices when they try to measure
something multiple times the
corresponding noises will be independent
so this is often a realistic assumption
and in addition the noise in the
measuring devices is usually independent
from whatever randomness there is that
determined the values of the phenomenon
that you are trying to measure so these
are pretty common and realistic
assumptions let us take stock of what we
have we have observations that are
determined according to this
nation where WI or noise terms now let
us make some more concrete assumptions
we will assume that the random variables
the Thetas are normal random variables
and similarly the WS are normal as we
said before they're all independent and
to keep the formulas simple we will
assume that the means of those random
variables are 0 although the same
procedure can be followed if the means
are nonzero we would like to estimate
the theta parameters on the basis of the
observations we will use as usual the
appropriate form of the Bayes rule which
is this one the Bayes rule for
continuous random variables the only
thing to notice is that in this notation
here X is an N dimensional vector
because we have n observations and theta
in this example is a 3 dimensional
vector because we have three unknown
parameters so wherever you see a theta
or an X without a subscript it should be
interpreted as a vector now in order to
calculate this posterior distribution we
need to put our hands on the conditional
density of X actually it's a joint
density because X is a vector given the
value of theta the arguments are pretty
much the same as in our previous
examples and it goes as follows suppose
that I tell you the value of the
parameters is here then we look at this
equation this quantity is now a constant
and we have a constant plus normal noise
so X I is this normal noise whose mean
is shifted by this constant so X I is
going to be a normal random variable
with a mean of theta 0 plus theta 1 TI
plus theta 2 TI squared and the variance
equal to the variance of WI we know what
the normal PDF is so we can write it
down it's the usual exponential of a
quadratic and in this quadratic we have
X I minus the mean of the normal random
variable that we're dealing with let us
now continue and write down a formula
for the posterior we first have this
denominator term which does not involve
any Thetas and as in previous examples
does not really concern us here we have
the joint PDF of the vector of Thetas
there's three of them because we assume
that the Thetas are independent the
joint PDF factors as a product of
individual PDFs and then we have here
the joint PDF of X conditioned on theta
now with the same argument as in our
previous discussion of the case of
multiple observations once I tell you
the values of theta then the x i's are
just functions of the noises the noises
are independent so the x i's are also
independent so in the conditional
universe where the value of theta is
known the x i's are independent and
therefore the joint PDF of the x i's is
equal to the product of the marginal PDF
so of each one of the x i's but this
marginal PDF in the conditional universe
of the Excise is something that we have
already calculated and so we know what
each one of these densities is we can
write them down and we obtain an
expression of this form we have a
normalizing constant in the beginning we
have here a term that comes from the
prior for theta not prior from theta one
here is a typical term that comes from
the density of X I which is this term up
here so here is what we have so
how should we now estimate theta if we
wish to derive a point estimate the
natural process is to look for the
maximum posteriori probability estimate
which will maximize this expression over
theta find a set of theta parameters
it's a three dimensional vector for
which this quantity is largest
equivalently we can look at the exponent
get rid of the minus signs and minimize
the quadratic function that we obtain
here how does one minimize a quadratic
function we take the derivatives with
respect to each one of the parameters
and set the derivative to zero we will
get this way three equations and three
unknowns and because it's a quadratic
function of theta these derivatives will
be linear functions of theta so these
equations that we're dealing with will
be linear equations so it's a system of
three linear equations which we can
solve numerically and this is what is
usually done in practice and this is
exactly what it takes to calculate the
maximum a-posteriori probability
estimate in this particular example that
we have discussed it turns out as we
will discuss later that there are many
interesting properties for this estimate
and which are quite general